keep in mind that to a geoscientist in
1906 the theory of plate tectonics the
fundamental mechanism by which we
understand how the planet works wouldn't
be formally accepted for another 60
years the earthquake struck at 5:12 in
the morning on April 18th 1906 the fault
slipped 21 feet in a matter of seconds
and as it slipped it sent out waves of
energy earthquake waves that rippled out
into the surrounding areas police
sergeant Jesse cook was standing on
Davis Street in San Francisco and he
watched the ground
undulate beneath him and he later wrote
it was this it was as if the waves of
the ocean were coming toward me
billowing as they came Davis Street
split open right in front of me a gaping
trench about six feet deep and half full
of water suddenly yawned and sprang up
on the sidewalk at the southeast corner
while the walls of the building I had
marked from my Asylum began tottering
before I could get into the shelter of
the doorway the walls had actually
fallen in word but the stacked up cases
of produce that filled the place
prevented them from collapsing part of
what makes the 1906 earthquake so
important to a geoscientist like myself
is that so many people made observations
like this they noted the time and the
intensity of the shaking and they
documented the destruction using
photography which is a new concept in
documenting earthquakes in the years
that followed the earthquake a team of
researchers gathered together to study
the earthquake in greater detail than
had ever been done before and the team
of researchers was led by this stud of a
man the head of the geology department
at UC Berkeley go bears his name was
Andrew Lawson and Lawson and his
colleagues set out again to dock
at the earthquake in greater detail than
had ever been attempted before because
they had access to much more information
a lot more data so they began to conduct
interviews with the survivors they
documented the destruction themselves
taking photographs and they make
countless measurements around the Bay
Area and collected the only 92
seismographic readings of the earthquake
none of which came from the United
States so that was hard work in 1906 in
the end Lawson and his team produced a
report cleverly called the Lawson report
and it totally revolutionized the
burgeoning field of seismology it was
also a 400 page document that very few
people read but hidden in those pages
embedded in those changes were the seeds
of ideas that would ripple out and
become embedded in the rock record they
began by just making observations Lawson
and his colleagues noted that the
earthquake appeared to have started on
the San Andreas Fault and while that
might sound obvious today that wasn't
known back then in fact in 1906 most
people geologists included thought that
earthquakes and all of the shaking
created the fault rather than the fault
generating the earthquake Lawson and his
colleagues also noted that the fault
had slipped horizontally rather than
vertically and again while that seems
like sort of a trivial observation it
slipped horizontally at the time it was
thought that earthquakes could only be
generated by vertical motions so with
these two seemingly simple deceptively
simple observations the Lawson report is
already radically transforming our
understanding of the natural world and
our relationship with it Lawson also
teamed up with a man named Grove Karl
Gilbert who is a legend too nerdy
geologists like myself
and Lawson and Gilbert set out to map
all 600 plus miles of the San Andreas
Fault through California not an easy job
in 1906 on foot and horseback through a
lot of poison oak but they ended up
making that trace and they ended up
documenting again all of these motions
along the fault these deceptively simple
observations and while those are very
important perhaps the most revolutionary
concept to be found in the Lawson report
belongs to this man a geologist from
Johns Hopkins University named Henry
Fielding Reed and Reed and his
colleagues came out to the Bay Area very
soon after the earthquake and they began
to make their own observations and
specifically they were interested in how
the landscape had changed
you know before and after the earthquake
and what Reed and his colleagues noted
is that the fault didn't appear to have
slipped the same amount every where in
fact they saw that it had slipped a much
greater distance where the earthquake
epicenter was and then as you moved away
from that epicenter along the San
Andreas Fault it seemed to slip less and
less and less and less as though the
crust itself were absorbing some of that
motion a little bit like a rubber band
just sort of elastically absorbing
something
this led Reid and his colleagues to
propose a new theory on the working
mechanics of earthquakes they postulated
that stress and strain would build up on
a fault over time a little bit like
stretching out that rubber band until
eventually the friction on the fault
could no longer hold and it would slip
and generate an earthquake the rubber
bands snapping back into place this
theory became known as elastic rebound
theory and to this day it is still the
best working hypothesis we have on the
fundamentals of earthquakes
[Music]